demand for life-saving covid19 antibody
drugs is on the rise just four months
ago drug maker regeneron reported an
average of less than 5 000 dose
deliveries per week by september the
number increased to over hundred and
fifty thousand doses this is happening
as hospitalizations remain high in late
august over a hundred thousand covid19
patients were hospitalized nationwide a
daily average not seen since last
winter's surge
this comes as the delta variant sweeps
through the country and healthcare
systems become overwhelmed for those who
are vaccinated severe illness and
hospitalization due to the coronavirus
still remains rare but millions of
adults remain unvaccinated and for
high-risk patients who do get sick
doctors are increasingly turning to
antibody drugs to treat them to
understand why they've become so
critical in the fight against covid19
you need to understand how they work
when patients are infected by the new
coronavirus their immune systems should
produce antibodies these immune proteins
bind to the virus and prevent it from
spreading throughout the body antibodies
against covid19 do this by blocking what
is known as a spike protein on the
virus's surface this protein normally
helps the virus latch onto and infect
cells but for some people their immune
system doesn't produce enough antibodies
to fight off the virus or it doesn't
produce them fast enough this is where
antibody drugs like the ones that
regeneron and eli lilly produce come
into play to manufacture these drugs
researchers isolate what are called b
cells from a recovered patient's blood b
cells are a type of immune system cell
that makes antibodies in the lab the b
cells are then mixed with spike proteins
derived from the coronavirus once
scientists identify the b cells that are
best at latching on to the spike
proteins they isolate the genes inside
the cells that produce the most
effective antibodies these genes are
then placed inside cells and are grown
in bioreactors to create new antibodies
and these highly specific antibodies are
concentrated into a liquid solution and
then injected into sick covenant 19
patients this gives the body a temporary
boost of antibodies that help it fight
off infection
in clinical trials regeneron's drug
which is a combination of two types of
antibodies reduced the risk of
hospitalization or death by 70 percent
in people with mild to moderate symptoms
this is a big reason why treatment
guidelines from major health
organizations now recommend the use of
monoclonal antibody drugs for certain
patients so this is a major
breakthrough in the care of covid19
patients we have expanded our
our tools to treat patients with covid19
and this is our first recommendation for
a therapeutic for those patients with
mild moderate disease the world health
organization also recommends the use of
regeneron's antibody drug for patients
who are severely ill giving them this
additional antibody seems to show an
effect and what effect is that a
reduction in mortality as many hospitals
continue to be overwhelmed demand for
antibody drugs remains high
[Music]